if you have cancer [your] doctor may recommend
Chemotherapy as part of your treatment
The Cell's Nucleus controls this process
Inside each nucleus genetic material called Dna contains the instructions for directing this process
sometimes the cells Dna becomes damaged
Normally the DNa responds by either repairing itself or instructing the cell to die
in cancer however the parts of the cells Dna that [directs] cell division become damaged
When these sections are damaged the DnA is unable to repair itself or cause the cell to die
Instead the unrepaired Dna causes the cell to grow and divide uncontrollably
into more damaged cells called cancer cells
a tumor forms as the cancer cells multiply and displace the normal cells
As the tumor enlarges it develops its own blood supply
Since cancer cells do not stick together as well as normal cells. They may break away and enter a nearby blood vessel
Cancer cells in blood vessels may travel to other areas of your body and form additional tumors. This is called Metastasis
additional tumors may form in areas such as the lungs
liver
and bones
Another way cancer may spread to other areas of your body is through your lymphatic system
cancer cells may enter Lymph vessels near the tumor
Then travel to small glands called Lymph nodes
if the cells pass through the nodes
They may continue to travel through your lymphatic system and form additional tumors
Chemotherapy drugs work by targeting fast-growing and reproducing cells [a] characteristic common to cancer cells
The tumor Shrinks as the cells stop dividing and die
most chemotherapy drugs work systemically as they travel throughout your body in your bloodstream as they circulate the
drugs damaged metastatic cancer cells in other organs
unfortunately chemotherapy drugs cannot tell the difference between
Fast-growing normal cells and cancer cells as a result these drugs also damage
Or irritate some of your fast-growing normal cells such as those in your bone marrow
digestive system and Hair follicles
Death Irritation or damage to these normal cells produces [side-effects] such [as] a weakened immune system
Nausea and Hair loss
the goal of Chemotherapy is to reduce or eliminate cancer cells in the original tumor and any sites of
Metastasis
In addition to being a primary cancer treatment doctors often use chemotherapy as a secondary treatment
before during or after other primary cancer treatments such as [radiation] therapy or
surgical excision of a tumor
Depending on the location and type of [cancer] you may receive chemotherapy drugs intended to circulate throughout your body
including pills
capsules or liquids taken orally and
Intravenous or intramuscular
injections
Alternatively you may receive drugs delivered only to the area of the tumor
One local method delivers drugs to your bladder or chest through narrow Tubes called Catheters
Another local method injects drugs into the cerebrospinal fluid surrounding your brain and spinal Cord
A third local method places slowly dissolving wafers into an area where a tumor was removed
In most cases you will receive a number of different chemotherapy drugs to increase their effectiveness
[you] may receive many chemotherapy treatments spread out over a period of weeks or months?
This allows your body to recover between treatments and to kill as many cancer cells as possible
common side effects of chemotherapy include hair loss nausea
decreased appetite
fatigue anemia
bruising and
diarrhea
It is important to rest
Eat Nutritious foods and take medications prescribed by your doctor to reduce or minimize these side-effects